Speaker 1: You know, I should really count
up all the times that we've talked about
Elon Musk's purchase of Twitter this year on the
show and on the bonus show, because it seems like
every other day we've been talking about this
whole saga because before the deal was made,
there was all this back and forth. There were
questions about whether Elon could actually
buy Twitter and that if he could back out from
the deal. And then ever since he's taken over,
there's been all these updates as to what the hell
is happening over at that company. And I find it
important to provide the updates because it's one
of these things where you have this high profile
person, the richest person on the planet, taking
control of one of the most important social media
sites. And he's been making a lot of mistakes and
costing himself and the company a lot of money in
the process. And there's this question now over
whether Twitter will be able to survive. And it's
turned into this total cesspool lately because of
the low staff and low level of enforcement. Well,
the latest stories that Twitter is going to be
relaunching its verification program this week.
Earlier this month, you may remember that Twitter
changed from having those coveted blue checks,
verifying high profile figures being something.
That was instituted automatically for people
with a big audience to something that you could
pay $8 a month for, even though even if you're
not some high profile figure yourself.
As long as you're willing to pay up,
you could get that highly coveted blue check.
Now, the first draft of this proposal failed
miserably because with the rollout and the lack
of moderation, there was just a great deal of
impersonation accounts with people paying for the
blue check and it became clear you just wouldn't
be able to trust anyone with this new system. You
couldn't tell if people were actually who they say
they were. Then Ellen jumped in and said that
impersonators and parody accounts would receive
a permanent suspension with no warning. You had
people impersonating Ellen himself, and you had
one account impersonating the pharmaceutical giant
Eli Lilly, which tweeted that insulin was free,
causing the company's stock to take a nosedive. So
it's all had some great consequences and it's all
been chaos. And even aside from all of this is
the reality that, you know, it's really taking
the whole point of being verified if you can just
pay for the service because like, there's really
not that much clout to being able to afford the
$8 a month charge. And at the same time, like
the point of verification is to to to know
with certainty that people are who they are.
You take that away if it's something that people
can just pay for. And there's really no sense in
just an average Joe being verified because who's
trying to impersonate their account to begin with?
Nobody. So Ellen has been making so many different
mistakes. Now what he's trying to do is add this
color coded system for verification. He tweeted
recently, Sorry for the delay. We're tentatively
launching Verified on Friday next week. Gold
check for companies GRE check for government,
blue for individuals, celebrity or not, and all
verified accounts will be manually authenticated
before check activates. Painful but necessary.
So from that post, it's unclear how exactly their
verification process is going to work. And if
you're even improving anything from the first
round, that was a total disaster. Like maybe an
individual user will no longer be able to pretend
to be a company or a government agency, but
that doesn't help all that much because there's
still plenty of celebrities that they can still
impersonate because they will have the same color
check as the people who were high profile. I think
this idea altogether is a total mess. Like I think
you need a verification process so that news
outlets and just everyday people can know that
when they see someone is tweeting something, that
it's actually that person and not someone else.
Another problem Twitter will continue to have
is all of these employees leaving. How are you
going to have enough people to manually verify
all of these different accounts? It just sounds
like a total nightmare. We know, of course,
that Elon's goal behind launching this paid
service was to increase revenue over that the
company, because they've been having difficulty
doing that. And when you're subject to the whims
of advertisers, it means that you're not well
diversified as a as a company because, you know,
you're just not all that recession proof. Like
if companies have less money to advertise, then
your revenue will plummet. And I'm certain that
that probably happened this year with the scaled
down in the economy that took place in 2022. So
maybe they want to just open up other streams
of income so you can be a little bit more well
balanced. But it doesn't necessarily mean that
this is the right way to go about doing it. This
never seemed to be the solution to me anyway.
Paying for verification, especially when you
look into the numbers like there are apparently
about 200 million Twitter users and they say
that that doesn't really include dead accounts
and accounts that people haven't used in a long
time. But I think the realistic number is probably
significantly less than that. And if if you also
have like a smaller portion of people who are
willing to actually pay for the Twitter blue,
how much money are you really going to be able to
raise from this system? Is it going to be anything
that compares to the $5 billion of revenue that
you did in 2021? Is it going to make that much
of a difference? And if so, does it make up
for the lack of credibility that you have,
the sort of trustworthiness that you give up by
changing this verification system over? My sense
is that it's probably not going to be worth it.
But Elon is trying he's trying to come up with
innovative ideas to bring about an extra stream
of revenue coming in. But this one seems to be
a total disaster and it doesn't seem like it's
working well and that if people are open to it.